notre histoire commence le 29 juillet
dernier lorsque Dieudonné annonce par
surprise l'arrivée d'un spectacle en duo
avec Jean-Marie Bigard dans tous les
élites de France Bigard Dieudo sur scène
à vous de jouer dans la foulée une
affiche du spectacle est dévoilée et une
billetterie aimée mise en ligne mais dès
le lendemain Jean-Marie Bigard
démantermement l'information sur les
réseaux sociaux il n'y a pas de
spectacle avec Dieudonné mais le 31
juillet la productrice de Jean-Marie
Bigard publie cette vidéo tu as écrit ce
spectacle avec Dieudo et en plus il y a
tellement de gens qui sont au courant de
ce duo tu en as parlé à tout le monde
que l'humoriste s'est engagée à faire ce
spectacle et déclare même quelques jours
plus tard que le show en duo aura bien
lieu Jean-Marie sera bien sur le
spectacle toute la France va se lever
pour applaudir ce fameux duo de choc
Jean-Marie Bigard et Dieudonné que le 9
août dernier Jean-Marie Bigard publie ce
communiqué et porte de son côté un point
final à cette histoire je devais monter
sur scène avec lui mais après réflexion
j'ai décidé de mettre fin au projet de
duo alors Dieudonné Jean-Marie Bigard
ont-ils vraiment préparé un spectacle à
deux toutes les révélations ce soir sur
notre plateau
merci Christelle Camus d'être avec nous
vous êtes productrice et du spectacle
donc vous étiez la productrice de
Jean-Marie Bigard je suis toujours
officiellement la productrice de
Jean-Marie Bigard jusqu'en décembre 2023
d'accord et vous deviez donc produire ce
spectacle à deux dieudonnées Jean-Marie
billard on va parler d'un instant et
j'ai la réponse de Jean-Marie qui m'a
écrit une réponse et qui sera peut-être
avec nous demain pour répondre à tout ça
alors est-ce qu'ils ont bien préparé un
spectacle ensemble Dieudonné Jean-Marie
Bigard alors oui le spectacle est
présenté
le spectacle part sur la route mais il
parle mais sans Majorie
Jean-Marie c'est peut-être ce qu'il dit
il ne sera pas sur la tournée pourquoi
parce que Laurent effectivement lui a
proposé de revenir aux grosses têtes et
Jean-Marie a énormément peur que en
disant qu'il est sur ce fameux duo qui
ne puisse pas faire le contrat avec avec
Laurent que j'apprécie énormément mais
ça c'est pas ça parce que Jean-Marie
parle de pression il utilise toujours
des mots un peu trop fort c'est pas
dépression c'est des conseils
quelques-uns de ses amis proches donc
toi tu au téléphone moi je l'ai eu au
téléphone cet été quand il m'a annoncé
ça il n'osait même pas me l'annoncer
c'était Lola d'ailleurs qui a annoncé
elle était à côté de lui et je lui dis
mais fais pas ça on a aimé c'est pas une
pression il fait ce qu'il veut il est
grand c'est juste un conseil un conseil
amical je suis pas le seul et il s'est
Moon évidemment Laurent Vinci j'imagine
François Rollin quelques-uns de ses
meilleurs amis parce que moi je fais pas
partie de son entourage proche on a été
plusieurs à lui dire ça va être la
connerie de plus
Jean-Marie donc j'imagine qu'après il a
réfléchi le reste ça me regarde pas je
me suis pas occupé du reste sur Laurent
c'est que effectivement il a été
conseillé alors il faut savoir que
Jean-Marie et Dieudonné avait préparé ce
spectacle déjà depuis des années c'est
un spectacle qui était prévu le titre
s'appelait foutu pour foutu et c'était
un visuel que Dieu donnait avait fait
donc tout venait déjà de Dieudonné il y
a 2 ans c'était Dieudonné Jean-Marie
Bigard c'était prévu il y a 2 ans
d'accord ensuite il y a eu le covid et
Jean-Marie il faut savoir que Jean-Marie
est très gravement malade Dieudonné
aussi et en fait ils ont voulu se
rassembler tous les deux parce qu'ils
savent que c'est leur dernier spectacle
et ce que vous nous dites
autrement je dirais pas ça mais bien sûr
élevé la 68 ans il a quand même moi ça
fait longtemps que je travaille avec
Jean-Marie je suis la femme de l'ombre
donc c'est vrai que je ne viens pas
forcément sur les plateaux accompagner
les artistes mais il a un diabète très
élevé il a une polyarthrite qui est très
élevée aussi et il a des problèmes de
coeur moi j'ai eu il y a quatre ans des
spectacles ont été annulés parce qu'il
nous avait fait des des AVC sur scène et
ça si Jean-Marie vient demain c'est
dommage qu'il ne soit pas présent parce
que c'est facile de venir après il
aurait mieux fallu qu'il y ait tout le
monde
je lui reproche pas grand chose moi je
suis une professionnelle c'était une
bonne idée le spectacle Dieudonné
Jean-Marie Bigard moi pour moi
on a augmenté ce qui a c'est que quand
Jean-Marie et Dieudonné ont annoncé sur
leurs réseaux sociaux ce fameux duo ils
ont vendu en 48 heures 35000 billets
c'est énorme
à peu près la place 50 40 euros
maintenant et 50 euros après parce que
par rapport qui est très cher alors je
suis tout à fait d'accord en tant que
producteur je le comprends aussi sauf
qu'on a l'agréable surprise de voir que
les les billetteries ne sont plus à 2
euros les frais de location mais sans
passer à 4,50 € chez producteur tu sais
comment ça se passe aussi pour
moi qui m'occupe de ça
augmenter tout a augmenté donc ce duo il
avait vraiment envie de le faire je vous
ai joint à l'équipe des échanges de la
fabrication
que j'ai envie de vous poser vous étiez
productrice que de Jean-Marie Bigard oui
il y a 10 ans j'ai produit déjà
Dieudonné sur ce que vous lui avez dit
c'est une bonne idée pour toi de faire
un spectacle avec Dieudonné écoute Siri
est-ce que vous avez parlé en tant que
productrice et on vous disant moi je
vais m'en mettre plein les poches où
est-ce que vous êtes dit je vais parler
pour Jean-Marie parce que je pense que
c'est une bonne j'ai un bon plan de
carrière
que il y a une production qui s'appelle
Jésus production qui est aux États-Unis
qui gère sa tournée moi je suis juste en
fait la productrice de la tournée de ce
duo moi je suis juste la productrice
exécutive en fait de cette tournée donc
je n'ai pas 100% de la billetterie il y
a Dieudo il y a Jean-Marie et il y a la
production américaine donc moi quand
Jean-Marie m'en a parlé effectivement de
faire ce duo j'ai dit écoute
effectivement Jean-Marie c'est mêlé à la
politique c'est mêler à insulter aussi
des ministres on sait très bien et puis
même dans le spectacle de de de parole
de complotiste quand Jean-Marie m'a
parlé qui voulait faire des émissions à
Ruquier je suis même resté bête parce
que dans parole de complotistes bon ben
il dit pas du bien malheureusement des
Grosses Têtes donc alors que moi j'étais
en train mais qui était en colère
il est pas rancunier et puis surtout on
connaissent les excès quand il est en
colère il est capable de tout ça je lui
pardonne ça j'ai pas de problème fais
vous n'allez pas m'apprendre quoi que ce
soit sur Jean-Marie Bigard ce soir mais
moi je lui pardonne contrairement à vous
parce que je vous trouve je vous dire je
voudrais pas avoir une productrice comme
vous hein descendu par quelqu'un comme
vous quand on est artiste bonjour
productrice de Bigard jusqu'en décembre
prochain je lui souhaite pas parce que
la façon dont vous en parler c'est
étonnant quand même
il le dit lui-même dans la presse
et pour Dieudonné on a qu'à appeler
Dieudonné il vous le confirmera et puis
il m'a donné l'autorisation d'en parler
producteur c'est vrai que ça sert aussi
à à conseiller à faire des choix de de
carrière je n'étais pas que sa
productrice j'étais aussi son agent
quand il y a des procédures justement
contre c'est une bonne idée
alors on en a discuté et c'est
Jean-Marie qui m'a dit Christelle je
suis foutue je ne remplis plus les
spectacles je ne fais plus de stats je
ne fais plus de Zénith je fais le point
virgule malheureusement je ne remplis
pas
une belle façon
si vraiment vous
êtes en mieux franchement
et puis je répète juste ici
vous êtes son avocat vous n'êtes pas
quelqu'un qui doit dire devant tout le
monde qui remplit plus Laurent je ne
peux pas défendre un artiste déjà qui
n'assume pas son contrat de production
comment vous avez besoin
il est en dehors du contrat quand vous
avez un contrat d'exclusivité on ne
passe pas chez quelqu'un et on demande à
prendre l'argent directement
ou alors pour l'instant attention pour
l'instant je n'ai pas engagé de
procédure
il devait faire ce spectacle et il vous
a dit qu'il le ferait plus alors il
ferait plus moi il m'a dit écoute on va
faire croire que je ne fais plus ce
spectacle comme ça je peux faire les
grosses têtes comme ça je peux prendre
mes cachets tranquillement
donc encore une belle façon de le
défendre encore Jean-Marie oui parce que
je veux pas lui faire perdre son argent
lol Laurent et du coup je donc je lui ai
dit ok va faire l'émission j'ai dit ok
c'est tout après quand il m'a posé la
question est-ce que je devrais le faire
j'ai dit écoute tu as plus rien à perdre
il avait plus rien à perdre Cyril pour
lui il arrive plus à il arrivait plus à
finir son spectacle à l'écriture et
c'est lui qu'il voulait d'ailleurs je
t'ai envoyé tous les messages ou tu vois
qu'il en parle même à des amis il en
parle à tout le monde en disant super à
partir du 1er août on va annoncer
l'événement ça va être grand dur et tout
donc il avait vraiment envie de le faire
moi je lui ai dit parce qu'il était
perdu et à un moment donné il écoute ses
amis et il réfléchit vous pouvez
comprendre ça ah mais Laurent Jean-Marie
les adultes il fait ce qu'il veut c'est
ce que je vous ai dit je suis sans
producteur sur le contrat il y a marqué
que je produis tous les spectacles de
Jean-Marie donc si demain il voulait
faire celui-là ou un autre je pouvais
pas mis opposé si je voulais mieux poser
je dois agir sur les cloches qu'il y a
dans le contrat tout simplement donc moi
quand il me dit je veux faire Europe 1
et qu'il comprend rendez-vous avec
Europe 1 parce que il voulait justement
avoir un créneau concurrence aux grosses
têtes du jour au lendemain il me dit je
vais faire les émissions et Laurent moi
j'ai pas jugé j'ai pas jugé ces gens
Marie effectivement on le connaît donc
je dis ok voilà il fait comme tu veux
reprendre derrière c'est vraiment que
Laurent il déclare
parce que j'ai plus confiance encore en
Jean-Marie quand madame voyez-vous parce
que vous avez de quoi faire
tu as besoin de Jean-Marie parce que
comme le dit Jean-Marie ce n'est plus
les grosses têtes d'avant et Jean-Marie
est un très bon est un très bon
raconteur de blague donc ça il faut le
dire donc je critiquerai pas Jean-Marie
parce qu'il va dans une émission ou une
autre que ça depuis tout à l'heure
n'arrêtez pas d'être négatif sur la
question est-ce que le Dieu qu'est-ce
que je pensais du duo moi je trouvais ça
super comme plein de gens même sont le
public de Jean-Marie était content
autrement n'aurait pas vendu justement
45 minutes
c'est Monsieur Faurisson négationniste
et révisionniste en costume
il y a 15 20 ans entre temps j'ai fait
Fox je n'ai pas eu de problème pendant
un an sur la tournée avec avec
Dieudonnée
à être monté sur scène avec Dieudonné
c'est Monsieur Faurisson négationniste
qui estime qui a jamais eu de camps de
concentration pardon mais ça fait
réfléchir écoute moi j'ai fait Fox vous
ne me tutoyez pas on ne se connaît pas
bien sûr on se connaît pas bien sûr
qu'on se connaît jamais rencontré avant
ce soir
avec Samantha Fox sur la
promotions
que ça a été champion mais je vous ai
pas vu vous voyez si on s'est vu on
avait la langue à côté bon c'est pas
grave
il y avait pas un mur il y avait surtout
la poitrine
et d'ailleurs de tuer on se tutoie à
chaque fois qu'on se revoit hein
donc ce spectacle
mais moi de toute façon
le problème en fait Jean-Marie ne fait
pas ce spectacle
Jean-Marie ne fait pas ce spectacle
malheureusement au terme du contrat je
devrais appliquer effectivement ce qui
aura à faire mais c'est une procédure
guillotine c'est comme le dit presque ça
peut être comme une guillotine parce que
on a pas faire un spectacle contre son
gré Christophe de l'argent
donc si demain il faut savoir Jean-Marie
à des dates là avec paroles de
complotiste là dans 15 jours il a des
dates de vendues avec son spectacle en
solo avec vous c'est vous qui produisez
d'accord donc on a quand même 4 ou 5
dates là en septembre
tout va bien parce que vous le
connaissez donc vous savez très bien que
demain il peut dire à quelqu'un [ __ ]
et puis d'après le prendre dans les bras
c'est Jean-Marie vous savez avec
Jean-Marie j'ai travaillé avec lui il y
a 4 ans il a il est parti avec un
producteur et ensuite il m'a rappelé en
novembre parce qu'il était au plus mal
et j'ai dit ok je te dis quand on est
quand on est pas bien on fait des
bêtises et je l'ai aidé comme je pouvais
voilà donc
elle a besoin de producteur alors donc
si il fait pas ce spectacle il va se
passer quoi bon Jean-Marie ben si
Jean-Marie effectivement alors c'est pas
qu'à moi parce que ça indique
c'est une affaire de plus de enfin moi
je parle pour entre les sociétés que je
représente ça peut monter jusqu'à 10
millions d'euros parce qu'il n'y a pas
que ma société en fait
Jean-Marie en fait avait un contrat de
production en fait qui qui est géré par
une société britannique et une société
française et il y a la société du
spectacle que j'ai parlé tout à l'heure
de la production américaine où on a
donné les droits pour que Jean-Marie et
Dieudo puisse faire cette fameuse
tournée avec Jésus production et ensuite
et ensuite il faut savoir la production
qui gère Dieudonné qui attaquerait
éventuellement Jean-Marie Bigard pour
lui réclamer effectivement des dommages
intérêts puisque Dieudo a effectivement
sa possession des éléments qui montrent
leurs échanges des textes des messages
Instagram donc on peut pas
malheureusement ce spectacle là aussi
était vendu à une production américaine
c'est ça le spectacle est géré par une
société voilà américaine qui est le
producteur Jésus production et moi en
fait je m'occupe de la de le gérer de
gérer en France est-ce que ça vous
dérange de travailler ou pas du tout
mais pas du tout j'ai travaillé avec moi
avec Dieudo il y a 10 ans ça s'est très
bien passé sur Foxtrot moralement
parlant oui je vais répondre à la
demoiselle parce que je j'écoute les
personnes moralement parlant je me suis
toujours mis des oeillères moi sur les
personnes je les juge pas moi je vois
que l'artiste qui a sur scène tout ce
qui se passe alors
comme vous Laurent
de la radio et de la télévision et je la
vesti justement sur des artistes que
j'ai fait de suivre et que j'ai cette
défordre quand je parle d'eux sur les
fleurs mais Laurent mais moi c'est moi
qui paye les zénithes c'est pas la
l'argent du gouvernement ou des fonds
dearité
moi c'est pareil tous mes spectacles je
les produits moi avec mon argent alors
donc vous êtes en train de nous dire que
Jean-Marie il risquerait de faire ce
spectacle parce que sinon ça lui
coûterait 10 millions d'euros au minimum
donc là on va le forcer à aller sur
scène non mais non s'il veut pas le
faire on peut pas forcer effectivement
un artiste
il peut avoir effectivement une saisie
par le Gex donc en fait c'est une saisie
conservatoire de ses contenu en
attendant que il y a une décision de
justice qui soit effectivement mais
attendez moi vous me voyez moi mais vous
ne savez pas
il a signé dans le contrat il y a pas
spécialisé qui doit donner son accord
pour faire ce spectacle Cyril c'est pour
ça que je vous ai envoyé le contrat dans
son signature non non si si une
signature parce qu'il a pas été manipulé
Jean-Marie Bigard dans cette histoire
parce que par exemple sur les réseaux
sociaux il y a la communication qui a
été faite sur son compte officiel et lui
a dit c'est pas moi qui suis derrière
effectivement on a parlé à sa place
alors effectivement bon moi quand ça
Jean-Marie a annoncé c'était prévu de
toute façon qu'ils annoncent le soir à
19h tous les deux le voilà ça les deux
postes étaient bons après Jean-Marie le
lendemain il a eu des pressions
effectivement comme le dit Laurent il a
eu d'énormes pressions des conseils
alors c'est lui qui dit dépression ça
n'a rien à voir tu dis les conseils mais
lui dis les pression lui le conseiller
comme pression donc pas comme des
conseils alors moi je lui ai dit que
c'était une connerie de plus voilà parce
que on sait et et Dieu sait et bien je
pense que vous ne l'ignorez pas au tout
début de l'affaire Dieudonné quand parce
que ça a démarré on s'en souvient avec
un sketch Chez Marco il faut également
j'ai été parmi ceux qui ont défendu dans
les dans un premier temps c'est pour
vous dire que je suis plutôt objectif
sur cette affaire-là parce que j'ai été
au début parmi ceux qui ont défendu
Dieudonné dont on sait que c'était un
des meilleurs humoristes à un garçon
talentueux des meilleurs auteurs à
l'époque et que au début il y a eu une
sorte de on va dire de d'escalade dans
la provocation déplorable et qui sert
ensuite retranché mais après il a
dépassé les bornes dépassé les limites
et il était devenu indéfendable même par
des gens c'était pas un ami mais même
par des gens qui l'appréciaient dont je
faisais partie alors donc vous voyez je
suis pas totalement antillonné mais il
faut dire que depuis ben oui mais sauf
que depuis des années et là il a il est
allé dans l'escalade et la provocation
qu'on peut pas pardonner et et voilà
pourquoi moi je fais partie et je suis
pas un ami de Jean-Marie je suis un bon
camarade mais avec Semoun avec
effectivement Laurent Baffie qui moi il
approche encore on lui a dit fais pas ça
ils m'ont cite aussi j'ai jamais pris
genre j'étais en train de bouffer des
culs en Provence
au milieu de ça ah mais je vous le dis
alors on m'a aussi accusé d'avoir appelé
une radio qui avait mis une affiche
c'est quoi comme radio alors je pourrais
pas citer le nom de radio qui avait mis
une affiche de Dieudonné et et
Jean-Marie Bigard et moi j'aurais appelé
le patron de la radio pour dire il faut
que tu relèves cette affiche de ton site
internet alors moi j'ai rien aucune
légitimité c'est-à-dire je connais même
pas le patron de la radio c'est pas moi
la radio rien n'est à moi même si rien
n'est qu'à moi hein j'aurais appelé
j'aurais dit non mais voilà il faut
enlever qui qui a sorti c'est cette
connerie c'est pour ça que c'est quoi
c'est comme ça Dieudonné qui a fait une
vidéo aussi disons qu'il avait envie de
me parler parce que il croyait il a cru
que j'avais vraiment enlever cette
affiche que je m'étais Molite mêlée de
cette affaire alors je vais tenir
Christelle cet été
sur un jet-ski euh
j'avais été à 1800 millions
[Applaudissements]
ils reviendra parce que les gens aiment
Jean-Marie Bigard et il s'est coupé
d'une partie du public avec les
différents voilà les différentes
polémiques qui a pu avoir quoi comme
spectacle ah non Dieudonné alors là je
vois pas je connais pas Dieudonné je
connais pas suffisamment moi je l'ai
jamais vu que le public aimerait ça mais
en tout cas ce qui se passe à l'heure
actuelle c'est que quand Jean-Marie
alors on va reparler des réseaux sociaux
quand Jean-Marie a annoncé effectivement
ce fameux duo et en même temps Dieudonné
et qu'ensuite il y a quelqu'un qui a
pris la main sur les réseaux sociaux de
Jean-Marie qui a dit je ne ferai pas ce
spectacle Jean-Marie l'a perdu
énormément son public énormément il
s'est fait le pauvre
démonté sur les réseaux sociaux le
créneau les réseaux sociaux c'est pas
tout public
un échantillon représentatif de
l'ensemble du public quand on colle des
affiches de partout
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je la prends je la prends j'ai une
soirée samedi soir j'ai besoin de drôle
parce que les artistes avaient décidé de
faire un spectacle où il se retrouve
devant Saint-Pierre et devant Dieu donc
en fait ils avaient trouvé l'idée d'être
mort tous les deux morts on va dire par
rapport à ce qui disait des horreurs ou
pas non pas du tout ah ben non autrement
il voulait en fait réunir
c'était un spectacle de Dieudonné si tu
savais pas que tu avais fait Fox
je l'ai pas danser ça monte
alors et donc si tu veux quand j'avais
fait il y a 10 ans Dieudonné sur Foxtrot
Dieudonné donc m'avait dit ma vie m'a
montré le texte et c'était parfait donc
on avait tous les soirs à Lucie et qui
venait constater les propos de Dieudonné
pour voir s'il y avait des propos
antisémites à citation à la haine la
tournée s'est passé entièrement les
zénithes étaient complets on avait même
des 200 300 personnes de gens qui
attendaient dehors pour pouvoir rentrer
et son spectacle était nickel sur ce
nouveau spectacle je réponds à ta
question ça ne parle que d'amour et de
religion ensemble pour tout réunir et de
dauphins si tu veux mais alors ça
parlait vraiment d'amour et de religions
réunis il n'y avait pas du tout de
propos d'institation à la haine ou de
repentance
je soutiens pas je trouve que c'est une
mauvaise idée pour
ça existe j'ai envie de le voir moi
j'aime pas leurs idées mais les deux sur
scène
ils font les homosexuels aussi sur scène
on s'attend pas on s'attend pas
tu veux toujours y aller je crois que
finalement il va couteau il va plutôt il
va plutôt rester ici
on arrive de Dieudonné c'est c'est très
étonnant donc alors moi écoute il va
faire ce spectacle ou pas écoute
honnêtement pour le bien de Jean-Marie
votre je préfère qu'il fasse parce que
pas attention pas que pour une histoire
d'argent mais surtout sur le public non
pour le public parce que le public
serait très destiné